[Musik]
das war mein erstes mal eine zigarette
und ich als nichtraucherinnen muss sagen
gar nicht mal so schlecht geschmeckt
nach mango nämlich die frage die ich mir
stelle ist sind e-zigaretten wirklich
gesünder als herkömmliche zigaretten und
wie sieht die wirtschaftliche lage
weltweit aus
die werbung nimmt den mund ziemlich voll
rauchen ohne risiko scheint da möglich
und das marketing geht auf in den
letzten jahren nahm der konsum rapide zu
allein in deutschland verfünffachte sich
der umsatz von 80 millionen euro im jahr
2012 auf etwa 550 millionen euro im jahr
2018 ab 2019 gingen die zahlen zurück
der grund in den usa und kanada starben
dutzende menschen nachdem sie e
zigaretten konsumiert hatten
nach den todesfällen gerät die branche
unter druck
teilweise wirklich einbrüche von 50 60
70 prozent bei den einzelnen
einzelhändlern aufgrund eben dieser
verunsicherung
doch studien der us behörden zufolge war
der hauptgrund für die todesfälle dass
verbraucher ihre e zigaretten mit thc
haltigen ölen streckten sogenannte
edreams die verunsicherung blieb dennoch
ist der globale markt weiterhin
profitabel vom umsatz sind die usa
weltweiter spitzenreiter in diesem jahr
gefolgt von großbritannien
in deutschland liegt die prognose bei
rund 870 millionen euro
doch in 41 ländern ist der verkauf
verboten darunter brasilien die türkei
und indien
hier müssen menschen sogar bis zu einem
jahr ins gefängnis wenn sie gegen das
gesetz verstoßen
mit ihrer entscheidung wolle die
regierung besonders junge menschen
schützen
die indischen e zigarettenraucher auch
welper genannt können die entscheidung
allerdings nicht verstehen
[Musik]
epping habe ich es geschafft mit dem
rauchen aufzuhören und dann als ich
aufhörte waren die vorteile groß ich
hatte meine ausdauer zurück meine
gesundheit wurde besser und ich konnte
wieder besser schmecken
ärzte warnen davor e-zigaretten zu
verharmlosen
zu sagen dass e zigaretten
ungefährlicher sind als normale
zigaretten ist eine irreführende
information gefördert durch die
e-zigaretten lobby eine lobby die der
onkologe seit jahren kritisiert aber
sind e-zigaretten wirklich so gefährlich
dass man sie verbieten muss gespräche
mit katrin schaller vom deutschen
krebsforschungszentrum
es sind auf jeden fall deutlich weniger
schadstoffe in dem modul enthalten als
in rauch enthalten ist ist auch kein
stück tabakrauch ist ja schließlich im
gemisch von tausenden von substanzen das
problem gesundheitlichen langzeitfolgen
sind noch nicht erforscht
entscheidend ist aber tatsächlich was
passiert langfristig wenn ich die diese
produkte täglich mehrfach und
wiederholten über monate und jahre
hinweg nutzen und das weiß man im moment
fest steht vor allem bei jungen menschen
besteht die gefahr dass süße
geschmacksrichtungen zum konsum
verleitet und so verschärft auch
deutschland künftig die gesetze die
bundesregierung legte fest ab 2021 darf
online nicht mehr für e zigaretten
geworben werden händler befürchten große
umsatzeinbußen für die gesamte branche
und ab 2024 ist auch außenwerbung
verboten das heißt plakatwerbung nicht
fassen und das halten wir für einen
großen fehler
zigaretten zu vermarkten wird weltweit
also immer schwieriger und ob sie
gesünder sind als herkömmliche
zigaretten es macht nicht ganz klar
langzeitstudien zu den gesundheitlichen
auswirkungen von e-zigaretten fehlen
noch
tatsache ist aber hinterlassen keine
zigarettenstummel auf den boden
für mich ist die e-zigarette aber keine
option
ich bleibe lieber nicht trocken
[Musik]